Тепер наполягати на сексі дорівнює спробі зґвалтування або і самому зґвалтуванню.
А без згоди на секс - не може бути і статевого акту.
Інакше надміру наполегливий коханець може потрапити до в’язниці на 3-5, а то й більше років.
Україна взялась втілювати в життя Конвенцію Ради Європи
про запобігання насильству стосовно жінок і домашньому насильству.
І для цього вже змінила статті Кримінального кодексу.
Проте попервах тема обов’язкової згоди на секс
викликала з-поміж людей хвилю жартівтаглузувань.
Дуже багато дзвінків з приводу розписок.Це якійсь жах.
Кожен третій, хто подзвонив на національну гарячу лінію із попередження домашньому насильству,
запитував: чи справді треба писати розписку, та кому її здавати.
Звичайно, ж ні про що таке не йдеться, відповідали у колл-центрі.
Для менеособисто, як для спеціаліста, як для людини, це дико.
Таке враження, що два тижні тому унас можнабуло де завгодно,  з ким завгодно,
і необов’язково була потрібна згода, а тутз 11 січнявже тільки за згодою.
Тема ця - аж ніяк не весела, а те, як люди реагують на зміни в законі,
показує про повне нерозуміння слова НІ у стосунках.
Ні означає НІ. Так само, як коли пропонуєш чашечку кави і наполягаєш, щоб її обов’язково випили:
байдуже, чи хоче кави людина, чи не хоче, може, вона саме спить, або знепритомніла.
П'ятдесятирічна Олена каже, що зміни до кримінального кодексу - це добре.
Але жінка не дуже розуміє, як саме їх можна втілити у житті.
І як це НІ реалізувати в шлюбі, особливо якщо насильство трапляється постійно.
СамаОлена в шлюбі 23 роки,п'ять з них - це нескінченне домашнє насилля з боку чоловіка.
Сексуальне насильство було… Коли я не хотіла з ним займатися, коли він був нетверезий.
Але мені здається, якщо в родині обидва тверезі, їм легше домовитися,
хто там хоче займатися сексом, а хто - ні.
А коли хтось напідпитку, то, тут звичайно, аргументи не діють.
Ночувати навстjячки, або куняти на вікні у під’їзді,
і водночас намагатися від усіх приховати свою трагедію.
Навіть поліцію не викликати - через почуття до чоловіка і небажання виносити бруд з хати.
Він міг мене вдарити. Я приходила на роботу, а у мене, припустимо, там синець.
Йому достатньо одного разу. Сила ж є в руках. Там садна, дещо іще було.
А потім ти думаєш, що це лише один раз. Проходить час, все ніби нормально.
А потім знов.
І ти не розумієш, що повільно котишся униз,
що ситуація стає дедалі гіршою, насильство - дедалі частішим.
Майже 100 повідомлень про домашнє насильство щодня надходить на гарячу лінію.
Типова історія така - чоловік вирішив жити окремо від дружини і вигнав її геть.
Ви маєте викликати поліцію. Вона забере речі та дитину.
Це його будинок? Його. Так, тоді лише зі співробітником поліції.
Кривдники стають дедалі молодшими. Вже йдеться про чоловіків від 30-ти років.
У Київському міському центрі роботи із жінками щодня мають справу з анонімними зверненнями
щодо усіх видів домашнього насильства: фізичного, психологічного, економічного і сексуального.
Часто жорстокість на рівному місці.
Тому що жінка, яка звертається до психологів
і мова йде в першу чергу про фізичне насильство.
Якась частина невеличка з'явилася за останні декілька років - це сексуальне насильство.
Жінки, які зазнали насильства, можуть ненадовго залишитися у київському міському притулку.
Тутешні психологи розповідають, що потерпілі дуже рідко готові говорити про сексуальне насильство;
адже навіть тут багато хто вважає, що в шлюбі чоловік має право на все,
і подружнє насилля не є зґвалтуванням.
Жінки воліють більше говорити про психологічний тиск,
про фізичне і економічне насильство з блоку благовірних,
а от про сексуальне - соромляться згадувати.
Вони такі змарнілі приїжджають. Навіть не хочуть зачіску робити, в халатах ходять.
Я їм кажу, ви що? У нас тут заклад.
Звичайно, коли їм вдома кажуть, що мовляв, кому ти там потрібна, що ти гірша за усіх…
В цьому притулку можуть одночасно жити лише дванадцятеро жінок.
Сюди, розповідає директорка, потрапляють жінки з різних родин –
втікають і від олігархів, і від сантехніків, і від правоохоронців.
І хоча адреси притулку немає в жодному довіднику, агресивні чоловіки навіть тут знаходять дружин.
Ось так підстереже в бінокль з сусіднього будинку дружину, а заразом і нас.
Ну, відстежують, хоча в нас і вивіски немає, номер телефону з довідника ми прибрали.
Ось був випадок, коли дружину з дитиною навколо будівлі ганяв. Ми викликаємо поліцію.
Вигнати дружину і дітей з дому - відповідно до змін у законі, вже не можна,
кажуть в громадській організації Ла Страда-Україна.
Зараз поліція та суди і мають достатньо інструментів впливу, щоб таки зупинити кривдників.
Особа, яка вчинила домашнє насильство три і більше разів,
може бути притягнута до кримінальної відповідальності.
В поліції є такий механізм як  терміновий заборонний припис.
і просто виставлення кривдника за двері прямо після того, коли це відбулося.
Він виноситься  на 10 днів.
Таким чином, поліція може обмежити перебування кривдника разом з постраждалою
або постраждалими особами.
В тому числі, в приміщення, яке, до речі,  належить йому на праві власності.
Суд може заборонити кривднику і на довший період наближатися до родини.
В Ла Страді сподіваються, що і поліція, і суди не зволікатимуть з виконанням нових приписів.
Але ось ця жінка такому геть не вірить.
Надії 66 років, вона ховає обличчя. У неї – своя біда.
Син примушував жінку віддавати йому пенсію,
зробив спільне проживання в однокімнатній квартирі неможливим.
Мовою закону це називається економічне насильство.
Та Надія особисто пересвідчилась, як поліцейські працюють на таких викликах.
І у дієвість нових законів - не вірить.
Цей закон мені не допоможе. Тому що виселити кривдника треба кудись в конкретне місце.
Якщо його виселити на вулицю, він ночуватиме під дверима, в під’їзді, на лавочці під будинком.
Життя тому, хто житиме в квартирі, не буде.
Він буде там заблокований в цих чотирьох стінах - та і все.
Людина може в цій квартирі вмерти, бо нікого не докличешся.
Надія хотіла б взагалі ніколи не повертатися у свою квартиру.
Приміром, якби держава могла виділити їй соціальне житло, жінка б охоче переїхала туди.
Проте в Україні поки не вистачає притулків навіть для жертв сексуального чи фізичного насильства.
У тому ж Києві є максимум 200 місць для жінок.
Громадські активісти сподіваються, що ситуацію змінять
спеціальні мобільні групи поліції під назвою "Поліна".
Це скорочена назва від "Поліцейські проти насильства".
Вони виїжджатимуть на виклики саме щодо домашнього насильства.
Чи відмовиться поліція від традиційної своєї практики не сильно вручатися в родинні справи,
поки не стане запізно, покажуть наступні кілька місяців,
коли по всій країні повноцінно запрацюють патрулі "Поліни".
І можна сподіватися, що жертви насилля більше не житимуть в постійному страху.